oh hello your highness hellooo say what
what could I do for you I highly
mathematical issue well what is it well
I knew did I have a fiber blueberries
one two three four five okay now that
sounds reasonable and I and I verify
that I can see that you definitely have
five blueberries here well what's the
problem well I'll see you that i have
three cherries one two three okay that
seems pretty straightforward yep you
have three cherries but I need to figure
out how many total pieces of fruit I
have and I do not know do I take five
and add three or do I take five and
subtract three I need something to do
with five ok ok Queen will calm down I
think our friends here can can actually
help us out a little bit so why don't we
let them pause this video and try to
think about it on their own so we know
we have five blueberries and we have
three cherries so the question is if we
want to calculate how many total pieces
of fruit do we have do we take five
blueberries and add three cherries to it
or do we take our five blueberries do we
take our five blueberries and then
subtract subtract three from it so all
that our friends pause this video and
think about think about which one
actually is describing this situation
that the queen is in ok ok
so I'm assuming they've they've had a go
at it so let's think about it when you
add something you're going to increase
the amount of fruit and when you start
with five blueberries we're increasing
it by three if you are subtracting 3
that means that you are taking away
blueberries or you're taking away pieces
of fruit so the situation you've
described is 5 plus 5 plus 3 if you did
5-3 that would be starting with your
blueberries so that would be starting
with your blueberries so let me whoops
let me make sure I can copy and paste or
redraw the blueberries here so copy and
paste so 5-3 would have been starting
with the five blueberries and then
taking away three so you take away one
two three I think I get it what I add I
increase the number of fruit if I'm
increasing the number of fruit I had if
I'm taking away and that's subtraction
subtraction is taking away so i know to
add so how many pieces of fruit do I
have well five plus three we can see is
this is five and then we have six seven
eight pieces of fruit so that's going to
be eight in total that's fascinating now
that you've taught me a little bit about
subtraction I'm also curious what would
5-3 be well we see it right over here we
started with five and you take away one
two three you're left with these
blueberries right over here you're left
with 12 blueberries so 5 minus three is
too oh that's just wonderful
oh I'm happy I could help you